STAND FOR.
OUR INSTITUTIONS WERE NOT
DESIGNED TO FUNCTION LIKE THIS
AND IT'S DISGRACEFUL AND
DISGUSTING.
>> Sean: THE SAME PEOPLE WHO
WERE SILENT OR ENCOURAGED OR
SAID THEY SHOULDN'T STOP
KAMALA HARRIS 574 RIOTS IN THE
SUMMER OF 2020,
KAYLEIGH McENANY.
THE SAME PARTY WHOSE SENATE
LEADER IS BY NAME SAYING YOU
WON'T KNOW WHAT HIT YOU AND THAT
BEING CHUCK SCHUMER AGAINST
SPECIFIC SUPREME COURT JUSTICES.
THEY ONLY CARE ABOUT ONE RIOT
AND NOT INVESTIGATING ANY OTHER
OF THE INCIDENCES.
HOW WILL THIS END UP?
>> THE PRESS SECRETARY SAID OH,
WELL, THIS IS DEMOCRACY.
IT'S DEMOCRACY?
WELCOME A PASS ALONG YOUR
ADDRESS PLEASE.
I'M SURE YOU WOULD WILLINGLY DO
THAT FOR PEOPLE TO PROTEST.
PEOPLE ARE UPSET, OKAY, I'M SURE
YOU WOULD LOVE IT IF PEOPLE WERE
DOING THIS AT YOUR HOME.
MEANWHILE, WHAT HAPPENED THAT
BRETT KAVANAUGH'S HOME WAS NOT A
PROTEST, IT WAS AN ASSASSIN WHO
CAME TO HIS HOME.
THE ONLY REASON THIS IS ALLOWED
BECAUSE IT'S ENABLED BY THE
MEDIA.
TODAY, I GOOGLED BIDEN
CONDEMNING ERIC CAVETT ON
ASSASSINATION.
SHE IS SEEING SOMETHING OVER THE
WEEKEND IF HE CONDEMNED IT.
THE HEADLINE WAS THIS, BIDEN
CONDEMNS ACTIONS OF MEN WHO
THREATENED JUSTICE KAVANAUGH.
THIS IS NEW, WHEN DID THIS
HAPPEN?
THAT WAS A HEADLINE FROM
JUNE 8TH.
READING THE ACTUAL WORDS OF THE
ARTICLES SAYING PRESS SECRETARY
CONDEMNED IT AND THE HEADLINE
SAYS BIDEN DID.
I'LL TELL YOU THIS, ANY TIME
TRUMP DID NOT SPECIFICALLY
DENOUNCE SOMETHING PRIOR TO THE
PRESS BRIEFING, IT WAS NOT
ENOUGH TO HAVE MY WORD,
PRESIDENT TRUMP WOULD ALWAYS
FOLLOW, BUT THAT WAS NOT ENOUGH.
THE HEADLINE WOULD HAVE READ
PRESIDENT TRUMP REFUSES TO
DENOUNCE THE ASSASSINATION
ATTEMPT BECAUSE IT WAS
INSUFFICIENT THAT THE
PRESS SECRETARY SPOKE ON HIS
BEHALF.
AT DIFFERENT ROLES OF THE GAME
AND THE PRESS ENABLES THE KIND
OF VIOLENCE THAT WE ARE SEEING
WHEN THEY ENABLE THE PRESIDENT
WHO WILL NOT CONDEMN IT.
>> Sean: IF ANY OF US GIVE OUT
THE ADDRESS OF ANY PROMINENT
DEMOCRAT OR LIBERAL
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE, I PROMISE
YOU, IT WOULD NOT GO UNNOTICED
AND WE'D PROBABL